sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation en association avec tv 78 une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg voici le sommaire
de ce nouveau numéro les pères
fondateurs de l'europe nous vous
parlerons de conrad adenauer un fervent
défenseur du projet de communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier
je recevrai l'eurodéputée sylvie brunet
on s'intéressera aux conditions de
travail et aux droits des travailleurs
des plateformes numériques
voyager dans l'assiette nous vous ferons
découvrir un plat typiquement suédois le
pain viande les superstitions en europe
et vul keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire quels sont
les croyances liées au mariage c'est ce
que nous verrons à la fin de cette
émission mais avant que fait l'europe
dans notre région un exemple tout de
suite
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
me voilà dans le village les a lus et le
roi dans le département des yvelines est
aujourd'hui je vais découvrir les
secrets de la confection des yaourts y
est pour cela je vais à la rencontre de
flavien tu es parti pour occuper
s'entraîner dans le labo il faut que tu
mettes un kit visiteurs composés d'une
blouse d'une charlotte de sur chaussures
et bien sûr d'un masque salut benoît
alors comme ça c'est toi qui détient la
recette des fameux yaourt étape numéro
un la ferme c'est là-bas que le livreur
récupère le lait pour le collectés dans
la citerne il sera ensuite vidé dont le
pasteurisateur pendant près de deux
heures et à 80° le lait va être
pasteurisé afin de tuer toutes les
bactéries l'étape suivante c'est la
chambre chaude puis l'enrobage le lait
devenu plus solide et placés dans des
bassines pour la fermentation une fois
cette étape validée le yaourt est
basculée dans du linge d'égouttage où il
restera deux à trois heures c'est
presque la fin la texture est brassée
avec une girafe afin de lui rendre son
aspect crémeux et onctueux combien de
kilos ça représente à chaque fois
puisque vous avez une bassine de 250 kg
donc on va me faire à peu près de 2400
peau enfin qu'il est brassée on va
remplir la trémie de
de là conditionneuse pour pouvoir leur
entière est conditionné en pot
l'équipe de benoit reçu un fonds de
soutien européen qui lui a permis de
financer en partie une confectionnés à
double entrée pour améliorer la
production mais ce n'est pas tout nous
asservir également à agrandir notre
heure flambeau froide donc là on a
installé une nouvelle chambre froide de
70 m² pour les collectivités qui ne
convainc pas 25000 peau non point pour
le voir à l'avance des commandes comme
on a quarante jours de dlc stocker et
puis ce fut tendu vient de sortir du
laboratoire vous venez de découvrir la
confection des yaourts y ici dans les
yvelines juste derrière moi il y à cet
entrepôt là également il ya la nouvelle
grande chambre froide financés par le
fonds de soutien européen
mais dans cet entrepôt il y avait
également l'ancienne boutique elle était
trop petit et donc maintenant il ya une
nouvelle boutique qui se trouve juste de
l'autre côté alors cela vient ici c'est
le comptoir de la grange est ce que tu
peux nous expliquer pourquoi c'est une
boutique on a lancé en 2018 pour mettre
en valeur l'ensemble des produits
français bien on a du fromage de la
charcuterie des produits d'épicerie des
desserts frais des tartines l'équipe de
benoit reçu de nombreuses récompenses en
2015 médaille d'or au concours général
agricole en 2016 victoire au concours
patrimoine francilien mais il ya aussi
l'entrée au salon international de
l'alimentaire une vraie référence pour
les tendances alimentaires la tendance y
sont en europe
comme chaque semaine nous vous faisons
découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
participé à la construction européenne
aujourd'hui l'allemand conrad adenauer
son parcours avec europe direct et la
maison de l'europe conrad adenauer est
un homme politique allemand né en 1876 à
cologne après des études de droit il
entre dans un cabinet d'avocats puis
commence sa carrière politique dans la
république de weimar il devient le plus
jeune maire de cologne en 1917 de 1921 à
1933 il est président du conseil d'état
de prusse sa carrière est brusquement
interrompue par la prise de contrôle
nazis en 1933
démis par hermann goering de toutes ses
fonctions en raison de son hostilité
affichée au nazisme il refusait par
exemple d'arborer le drapeau nazi à côté
du drapeau allemand il est emprisonné
brièvement après la nuit des longs
couteaux en 1934 puis entre en juillet
et novembre 1944 après l'attentât contre
hitler en juillet
ce n'est qu'après la seconde guerre
mondiale en septembre 1949 que le
parlement fédéral allemand lui confie le
premier poste de chancelier de la
république fédérale d'allemagne qu'il
occupera jusqu'en 1963 période à clé
l'air adenauer il est considéré comme le
fondateur de l'allemagne moderne
adenauer travail fortement pour
l'intégration européenne de l'allemagne
ils signent successivement les traité
créant la ceca et la cee l'allemagne est
l'un des membres fondateurs de ces
traités et rejoint le conseil de
l'europe en 1951 et l'otan en 1955 le
chancelier allemand se penche
particulièrement sur une coopération en
matière de défense européenne cette
coopération a débuté en 1949 puis s'est
poursuivie pendant la guerre de corée et
les discussions internationales l'idée
se concrétise avec le projet de la
communauté européenne de défense c'est
ed l'idée partagée avec jean monnet et
de créer une armée européenne composée
de contingents allemand le traité et
signer par les six états fondateurs de
l'europe cependant il est rejeté en 1954
par l'assemblée nationale française ce
qui a ralenti pendant un certain temps
le processus d'unification européenne
sa volonté de réconcilier la france et
l'allemagne après la seconde guerre
mondiale est plus forte et c'est pour
lui la clé pour maintenir une europe
pacifique et unis cette amitié franco
allemande est scellée en 1963 avec le
traité de l'elysée signé par de gaulle
et adenauer le 22 janvier devient par la
suite la journée franco-allemande qui
célèbre l'union entre les deux pays
conrad adenauer cite souvent l'idée de
victor hugo des états unis d'europe pour
une union économique qui mènera à une
entente politique entre les pays il est
la cible de nombreuses critiques qui
voient l'intégration de l'allemagne en
europe comme un obstacle à la
réunification du pays il soutiendra
durant quatorze ans que la réunification
européenne mettra fin à la division de
l'allemagne
malheureusement malgré sa politique
volontariste il ne peut que subir
l'édification du mur de berlin en 1961
il démissionne en octobre 1963 et meurt
quelques années plus tard en 1967
zone europe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui sylvie brunet vous
êtes eurodéputés membres du groupe
renault est membre de la commission de
l'emploi et des affaires sociales
bonjour bonjour alors depuis de
nombreuses années le monde et par
conséquent l'europe voit apparaître de
nombreuses plates formes qui permettent
de mettre en relation des travailleurs
et leurs clients pour un service donné
alors par exemple louer un hébergement
commandé à manger un service de
coursiers ou encore commander un taxi ou
un vtc avec des applications comme über
free n'a ou nietzsche pour les pour les
vtc se pose alors la question des liens
qui existent entre les travailleurs et
ses applications les conditions de
travail pour ces travailleurs comme dans
la majorité des cas ces travailleurs
sont dans sont indépendants et
bénéficient d'aucune protection sociale
comparer un employé plus traditionnelle
alors de quelle manière le parlement
peut-il influencer ses plateformes pour
trouver un réel cadre stable pour ses
employeurs et c'est d'ailleurs l'objet
d'un rapport que vous avez signé alors
en effet on voit augmenter année après
année le nombre ce qu'on appelle ces
travailleurs des plateformes d'affaires
en fait qu'ils travaillent par
l'intermédiation d'un algorithme d'un
logiciel généralement une application
sur leur téléphone
c'est quand même aujourd'hui ans dans
l'union européenne environ 24 millions
de travailleurs donc c'est pas rien et
c'est normal digitales étant là c'est un
facteur en pleine croissance
s'il ya bien un sujet qu'on doit traiter
au niveau européen c'est celui-là parce
que ces grandes plateformes font
intervenir des travailleurs dans
différents pays de l'union européenne
donc on peut pas se dire qu'ils vont
avoir un statut donné à dans un pays et
puis un autre statut dans un autre ça
entraîne vraiment pour le coup à fort
déséquilibre et et tout le monde réclame
justement qu'un un cadre européen pour
ses frères des plateformes la vraie
question c'est que effectivement il ya
deux statues qui existe aujourd'hui sur
le travail en europe soit le travail
indépendant ce qu'on appelle en anglais
le self employed
soit la relation de travail qui se
traduit la plupart du temps salariale
notamment en france pas toujours c'est
la relation de travail donc on a ces
deux statues il est vrai que la plupart
de ces personnes donc qui ont un contrat
plutôt commerciale avec les plateformes
son statut de travail indépendant et on
a vu émerger une problématique de
protection sociale parce qu'elle n'est
pas la même dans tous les états membres
en france on a un statut de micro
entreprises ce qu'on appelait
auto-entrepreneurs où il ya quand même
une forme de protection c'est pas
forcément le cas dans tous les états
membres et le deuxième sujet c'est que
certains sont analysés comme des faux
travailleurs indépendants dire que ni
les ont pas vraiment autonome ils n'ont
pas la liberté de choisir leur activité
ou pas de fixer leurs tarifs et donc là
il ya un vrai sujet et on peut penser
qu'ils sont peut-être présumé
salariés ou en tout cas avec une
relation de travail c'est pour ça qu'on
a rendu ce rapport pour que tout le
monde ait accès à une vraie protection
sociale notamment en matière d'accidents
du travail et qu'il y ait un
renversement de la charge de la preuve
si un de ces travailleurs va devant un
tribunal en disant ben moi je suis
désolé mais je considère que je suis pas
un vrai travailleur indépendant
d'ailleurs on m'a déconnecté je sais
même pas pourquoi j'ai pas de protection
la bloquer wallah ou bloqués bon autre
sujet ces travailleurs les clients
peuvent les noter sur les applications
est ce que vous pensez que c'est normal
qu'on puisse noter que alors qu'on
puisse expliquer s'il ya eu des
problèmes avec avec cette personne c'est
le principe de ces applications mais
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est normal
qu'on puisse noter n'importe qui dans
son travail de la vie de tous les jours
est ce que vous notez votre banquier
quand vous allez à la banque où voter
votre style alors bis postale c'est un
des grands phénomènes qui émerge un
depuis des années vous remarquerez qu on
note tout vous parliez de la manque
c'est vrai vous allez voir vous avez
vous recourez à une prestation à la
banque vous allez à votre agence vous
recevez un mail dans la suite comment il
va vous évaluez voilà rentrent en compte
bon je pense que c'est une évolution des
choses qui après tout peut-être pas si
mal à condition que cela soit
transparent c'est le vrai sujet c'est la
transparence vis-à-vis de ces fameux
algorithme
et là je reviens sur le travers des
plateformes bon ils souscrivent
effectivement une application et on va
leur rétrocéder une partie de la
devise sur ce que touche la plateforme
elle-même vous avez une course la
plateforme touche tant elle va
rétrocéder bien sûr une certaine partie
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si un
problème soit la note par exemple et
donc nous on a dit dans le rapport qui
va sachant au passage qu'il va y avoir
une directive sur les travers des
plateformes a priori en décembre on est
presque sûr qu'il y aura une directive
donc ce rapport était important parce
qu'il pose les bases de ce que nous
souhaitons parlement donc il faut qu'
une vraie transparence que ces
travailleurs quand ils sont indépendants
puissent être représentées
collectivement parce que c'est avec déjà
un collectif ils ont après tout les
mêmes conditions de travail puisque ils
sont déjà un collectifs reliés à une ou
l'autre plateforme qui puisse savoir ce
qui se passe sur les bases de données
aussi ils sont rentrés d'intervention
père comment on les récupère comme vous
dites il ya une note qu'elle soit disant
mauvaise peut-être s'est justifié
peut-être que ça n'allait pas ça doit
pas ils doivent pas se ça doit pas avoir
trop de conséquences au 605 et des
risques qui existent par exemple les
pays asiatiques oui il ya des dérives
dans
dans beaucoup d'endroits parce qu'il ya
de telles masses de données maintenant
que bon c'est pas toujours on voit bien
on tousse en ce moment c'est tout le
sujet du digital on va pas enrayer cette
évolution mais en même temps il faut
quand même que les gens soient protégés
et une fois de plus tu t'es tu mets le
travail il ya deux statues il n'y a pas
de raison qu'on ait des faux
travailleurs indépendants qui n'ont pas
la même qu'on reconnaît que certains
travailleurs sont inscrits sur plusieurs
applications oui et si demain ils
deviennent employés d'une de ses
applications ils ne pourront pas
proposer leurs services sur une
application concurrente et que certains
soient finalement plutôt content
peut-être pas la majorité mais de ce
statut un peu particulier en sont
absolument et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
c'est une très bonne réflexion on à nous
dans le rapport on a prévu que les deux
statues et coexistent vous avez raison
il ya beaucoup de ces travailleurs qui
pour différentes raisons préfère ce
statut travail indépendant est l'une des
conditions qui va explicité au tribunal
que vous êtes bien travailleurs
dépendance et le choix possible d'être
sur plusieurs plateformes très bien
merci beaucoup sylvie brunet d'avoir été
notre invité je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputés membres du goût du groupe
renault europe et de la commission de
l'emploi et des affaires sociales
zone europe voyage
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine
direction la suède robert jarl le chef
du restaurant lilac rügen à saint
germain en laye dans les yvelines nous
dévoile la recette de son pain de viande
bonjour je suis chez flaubert je tienne
le reste lente lille a créé au ghana à
saint-germain-en-laye depuis
maintenant sept ans
émond aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer
le fan devions tuer une flat serait
stupide suédois qui est la fille est
plutôt est
ce qu'on m'a dit une plaque quotidienne
qui moi je à revisiter à man version
pourrait être plus adapté à la
restauration dans la recette on a le
viande hachée des oignons des carottes
des pleurotes et et on utilise aussi une
appareil avec deux chapelets des oeufs
et du clair pour avec ça on va réaliser
une
ketchup de betteraves et framboises et
pour ça il ne faut des oignons noyer le
framboise de betteraves et du tout mais
on va commencer à préparer le vaste de
les recettes qui est le pain de viande
en soi même on a raison de tendre
le cash flow dans le poêlon naître les
unes peu d'huile pour faire revenir
d'abord
les sogno
et on va laisser on laissait les oignons
puis il en faut pour devenir le petit
port
plus mou qui les carottes c'est le plus
bas c'est cela qui est le plus dur
en puissant quoi bon
et voilà on est des oignons
et appelait avec ça on plante de une
petite peau du foie blé pois bleu noir
comme cas c'est
maintenant on va laisser ça aime bien
ceci avant on est maîtres de l'est plus
rock
le plus rapidement tâche est
comme ça maintenant les oignons et le
[Musique]
les carreaux est saisie on a notre
viande hachée dans ce cul de poule on
ajoute à on ajoute le apparaît avec de
chapelure des oeuvres et du clem on
ajouterait une petite
vaisselle
et
voilà on peut mettre en poney de maître
de l'europe
il pleut bien cessé jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
réduire à peu près à la moitié et le les
oignons et les carottes ils sont de plus
que le compte qu'ils sont bienne
sont bien debout et que les pleurotes a
pris une toute petit peu de colonnes et
ensuite pour réaliser leurs tubes et
robe framboise
comprendre un peu d'huile de tournesol
on laisse ça chauffe bien
[Musique]
on a essayé ces deux
le betteraves les framboises les tomates
du balsamique et moi j'utilise une
produit suédois ces deux cellules su que
les deux mélasse on sait de menace le
sucre de lait
deberdt à sucre
quand les oignons commence à colorer et
c'est bien un concept bien chaud dans la
poêle on ajoutera le sucre
voir
[Musique]
conde quand les le suc a bien calculé
sait on des glaces au vinaigre
balsamique
on a juste notre framboises les
betteraves
les tomates
et on est saluée avec
avec un petit peu de poivre
et de sel
et maintenant quand notre
dose mélange du bureau et de leurs
enfants nés entre 40 et play
on mélenchon
ça ensemble avec nous apparaît à chaque
lot
clem et 2
après on ne mélange
à la main
[Musique]
rolala on à la patte qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
après contre la pâte
les mélanges de lyon mathieu et ça c'est
bien
et c'est pour ça on appelle ça le fan de
lyon après contre la pâte
le mélange de lyon mathieu et ça c'est
bien
et c'est pour ça on appelle ça le podium
appelons valeurs entourées avec les
laves fait main
on m
quand des huiles dans une plaque pour le
four
on le mettrait le pain de viande
et on va mettre ça au four à 175 degrés
pour environ 35 40 minutes
et comme
quand les catcheurs
accueilli jusqu'à ce qu'ils les oignons
les oignons les betteraves est rien nous
viennent bien compris on mettrait sa
danse nixon milk se remet dans le
blender et on ajoute les goûts les sel
et le poivre rosso qui ce qui peut
manquer selon ces langues ou plus con
c'est bienne réduite on met très
sagement attendu dans le blender
pour a
[Applaudissements]
après qu'on a passé le
notre ketchup dans le bundle on a on a
vérifié que le goût il ne va ici on le
mettrait dans une bouteille pour pouvoir
faire des décorations sur les assiettes
aussi semble pour vous d acheter
une bouteille si vous voulez faire
redescendre
pour le dressage on utilise notre
bouteille on peut faire une petit
grillage comme ça
[Applaudissements]
en place le permis aux
petits oignons
et avec ça pour le petit couleurs et
pour faire un petit peu plus festif on
mène deux petites salles
quelques petites comme combat renner
et voilà c'est ça le le pain de viande
suédois
sous drop
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine au
mariage donc une grande affaire de la
vie c'est le mariage il ya beaucoup de
superstition qui sont liées au mariage
et surtout
des mariages heureux donc les choses a
fait watts va faire il y en a une liste
pour ne pas avoir d' influence néfaste
la jeune future mariée ne doit jamais
s'habiller dans sa nouvelle maison elle
va s'habiller là où élèves chez ses
parents et elle ne doit jamais se
regarder dans la glace
une fois qu'elle a revêtu sa robe de
mariée elle ne doit pas se regarder et
sortir sinon ça serait vraiment
porte-malheur elle doit aussi
porter sur elle quelque chose de vieux
et cette chose ne doit pas être blanche
parce que le blanc il ya beaucoup de
superstitions liées aux blancs par
analogie avec la couleur du cadavre et
cetera donc quelque chose de couleurs
nos amis anglais ont une superstition
qui est amusante
on va dire à l'aide cette superstition
est liée à ce dicton anglais on va dire
qu'il faut porter quelque chose de vieux
quelque chose de traiter quelque chose
de neuf et quelque chose de bleu
et avec ça on n'est à l'abri de toute
influence néfaste
ça vient d'un dicton qui dit something
old samse miniou something borrowed
comme cible ou voilà donc c'est la
traduction et les c'est toujours on
prend des jeunes filles aujourd'hui
c'est amusant c'est de voir qu'elles
connaissent la tradition d'avoir ces
quatre choses là en même temps pour un
mariage heureux
son europe
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations
également sur tv 78 rendez vous la
semaine prochaine très bonne soirée
sonne europe / sensations
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france